IT'S A BIG WEEK FOR ADAM SCHIFF
AND DEMOCRATS RUNNING THE
IMPEACHMENT SPECTACLE.
AFTER THE HEARSAY SHAM FAILED TO
DELIVER, THEY ARE NOW SET THE
CALL EIGHT NEW WITNESSES OVER
THE NEXT FEW DAYS.
AND THEN SIMPLE LUCY TAUNTING
PRESIDENT TRUMP, DARING HIM TO
TESTIFY.
CHECK THIS OUT.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT CAN COME
RIGHT BEFORE THE COMMUNITY AND
SPEAK ALL THE TRUTH HE WANTS.
HE COULD DO IT IN WRITING.
HE HAS EVERY OPPORTUNITY TO
DEFEND HIS CASE.
BUT IT REALLY IS A SAD THING.
WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID IS SO
MUCH WORSE THAN WHAT EVEN
RICHARD NIXON DID.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAYING HE LIKES THE IDEA AND
WOULD STRONGLY CONSIDER IT.
TRUMP IS CALLING OUT WITNESSES
OVER THE WEEKEND.
PELOSI RESPONDING WITH THIS
CHEAP SHOT.
>> HE SHOULD NOT FRIVOLOUSLY
THROUGHOUT INSULTS, BUT THAT'S
WHAT HE DOES.
I THINK PART OF IT IS HIS OWN
INSECURITY AS AN IMPOSTER.
I THINK HE KNOWS FULL WELL THAT
HE'S IN THAT OFFICE WAY OVER HIS
HEAD AND SO HE HAS TO DIMINISH
EVERYONE ELSE.
>> Jesse: WOW, IMPOSTER BUT
WHILE PELOSI AND SCHIFF PLOW
AHEAD, ONE DEMOCRATS WARNING
THAT THE PARTIES IMPEACHMENT
OBSESSION IS CALLING DOMINIC
TEARING THE COUNTRY APART.
SPEAK WHAT I'M HEARING IS THAT
THEY ARE KIND OF TIRED, THEY ARE
WORN OUT, THEY ARE BORED.
WE SPENT MILLIONS OF DOLLARS, IN
MY OPINION, TONS OF MONEY, TONS
OF TIME, TONS OF HURT,
FRACTURING THE NATION APART.
I DON'T SEE THIS TO BE A GOOD
THING.
>> Jesse: I YOU HEARING THESE
ON THE STREET, DANA?
>> Dana: I DON'T REALLY GO
OUT.
I THINK I SPOKE TO A TOTAL OF
FIVE HUMANS IN 48 HOURS.
THE LAST WEEK, I WAS QUIET BUT
READ A LOT.
I WRITE A NOVEL.
AND I WATCHED A LITTLE BIT OF
THE COVERAGE SO I COULD KEEP ON
TOP OF THINGS.
I FEEL LIKE GOING INTO THIS
SECOND WEEK, THE DEMOCRATS
ALREADY HAVE THE BURDEN OF PROOF
AND IT'S A REALLY HIGH ONE.
LAST WEEK I DON'T THINK THEY MET
IT BECAUSE EVEN FROM THEIR OWN
ADMISSION, THE OWN COVERAGE,
THEIR OWN HEADLINES, A LOT OF
THE COVERAGE OR IF YOU LISTEN TO
SOME OF THE PODCASTS WHERE THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT HOW THE
DEMOCRATS FELT AFTER WEDNESDAY'S
TESTIMONY IN PARTICULAR, GUYS,
ARE WE GOING TO BE ABLE TO KEEP
IT GOING, THEY CONTINUE TO TELL
THE SAME STORY OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IT'S A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
I THINK THE PEOPLE COMING TO THE
CONSENSUS IS THIS IS NOT
IMPEACHABLE.
WHETHER YOU THOUGHT IT WAS
APPROPRIATE OR NOT, THERE IS AN
ELECTION HAPPENING IN LESS THAN
12 MONTHS FROM NOW AND THAT'S
WHAT PEOPLE SHOULD MAKE THE
DECISION.
THAT'S WHERE THINGS ARE AT THE
MOMENT.
>> Jesse: THEY COULD'VE
HANDLED THIS WITH AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING.
>> Greg: I WAS ACTUALLY ON THE
STREET.
>> Dana: LOOKED LIKE YOU
SLIPPED THERE.
>> Greg: IT WAS A ROUGH
WEEKEND.
I TALKED TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
4,000 PEOPLE.
I WILL TELL YOU THIS.
WE MAY BE REQUIRED TO AIR,
AND THEN THEY SCOLD YOU FOR NOT
GENUFLECTING BEFORE THE ALTAR OF
SOLEMN NEWS FOR THIS IS
HISTORICAL, THEY TELL YOU.
NO, THIS IS HYSTERICAL.
THE RESENTMENT THE MEDIA HOLDS
FOR ANYONE WHO DOESN'T SWALLOW
THEIR GARBAGE IS USUALLY GIVEN
METAPHORICAL FINGER.
TO TAKE THE ANTI-KAVANAUGH MOB
SERIOUSLY BEER THEY'VE BEEN
WRONG EVERY TIME.
IT'S BEEN ALL GARBAGE.
BY THE WAY, OUR RATINGS ARE
GREAT SO I THINK WE CAN SAY THIS
BUT WE CAN TAKE ONE FOR THE
TEAM.
THEN
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, B
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, J
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, C
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, K
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, F
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, R
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, T
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, A
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, H
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, R
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, E
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, A
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, .
PAGE WATCH THE ROCKFORD FILES, "
SPEAK HOW ABOUT "PERSON OF
INTEREST."
WHEN YOU SAID THAT THEY HAVEN'T
MET THEIR BURDEN OF PROOF YET,
HERE'S THE BOTTOM OF LINE FOR
THEY SHIFTED THE BURDEN OF
PROOF.
NANCY PELOSI GETS OUT THERE AND
SAYS, MR. PRESIDENT, COME IN AND
PROVE YOUR INNOCENCE PAIR THIS
IS AMERICA.
YOU DON'T SHIFT THE BURDEN OF
PROOF, EVEN THOUGH WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT HE'S ACCUSED OF, WE KNOW WE
ARE GOING TO GET HIM.
JOHN DEAN SHED HELMICK SAID, HE
SHOULD HAVE BEEN IMPEACHED THE
FIRST DAY.
ARE YOU STUPID?
YOU ARE A LAWYER.
HE HASN'T DONE ANYTHING YET.
THESE PEOPLE SAY HE SHOULD COME
IN AND PROVE SOMETHING, TRUTH
THE POWER.
THEY ARE NOT NUTS, THEY ARE
BONKERS.
WE HAVEN'T STOPPED GIVING THEM
PRESS ON THIS STUFF BECAUSE
NOBODY CARES.
IT'S A BUNCH OF HOGWASH.
IT'S A BUNCH OF TELEPHONE.
IT'S A BUNCH OF RUMORS, HEARSAY,
GET OVER IT.
>> Dana: I THINK IS IMPORTANT
TO COVER IT SO YOU CAN ACTUALLY
CALL THEM OUT ON EITHER SIDE.
IF YOU DON'T DO THAT, THERE IS
ONLY ONE THING.
>> Jesse: SO DON'T WATCH "THE
ROCKFORD FILES."
JUAN, WOULD YOU RESPOND?
>> Juan: YES.
I DID GET THE IMPRESSION WHAT
THE RIGHT IS SAYING HERE, PLEASE
DON'T WATCH.
DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO
IMPEACHMENT THAT YOU'D BE SMART
TO GO WATCH WHATEVER.
HERE IS WHAT THE REALITY IS.
THE REALITY IS ABC NEW POLL,
THEY THINK THE PRESIDENT
REQUESTING A FOREIGN LEADER GET
THERE ON HIS POLITICAL RIVALS IS
WRONG.
>> Greg: HOW THE QUESTION IS
FRAMED, ONE WILLIAM ZELNICK.
>> Juan: 51% FROM A MAJORITY
OF AMERICANS SAYING THE ONLY
IMPEACHED TRUMP BUT REMOVE HIM.
GET THIS.
21% IN THIS ABC POLL ARE SAYING
THEY AREN'T PLAYING THAT MUCH
ATTENTION.
THAT SHOULD PLEASE.
THE PEOPLE WHO WERE PAYING
ATTENTION FOR THE FIRST WEEK, AT
66%.
TWO-THIRDS SAID IMPEACH AND
REMOVE.
>> Jeanine: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
THEY ARE DOING?
THEY ARE DOING SO THEY DON'T
HAVE TO PAY FOR POTATO HAVE TO
BUY APICAL AD FOR THEY ARE
TRASHING THE GUY.
>> Juan: STOP!
>> Jeanine: DON'T TELL ME TO
STOP.
DO NOT GO THERE!
[CROSS TALK]
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING!
>> Jesse: I WANT TO JUMP IN
FOR ONE THING BECAUSE YOU
MENTION THESE POLLS AND WE HAVE
POLL SHOWING THAT 77% OF
DEMOCRATS THINK TRUMP IS A
RUSSIAN AGENT THAT THERE'S A LOT
OF PEOPLE OUT THERE
BRAINWASHED --
>> Juan: BRAINWASHED...
>> Greg: DO YOU KNOW WHAT
TRUMP IS SUFFERING FROM?
FOR EMPLOYMENT.
HE HAS THE LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT
IN HISTORY, SO THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE WORKING CAN'T WATCH THE
HEARINGS BUT HE'S HURT
HIMSELF -- SO MANY AMERICANS ARE
BACK TO WORK THEY CAN'T WATCH
THE BRAINWASHED GOING ON.
HE SHOULD HAVE A TERRIBLE
ECONOMY SO THEY CAN ALL WATCH
THE IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
>> Juan: YOU CAN WATCH IT FROM
JAIL, ROGER STONE,
PAUL MANAFORT, YOUR BEST PEOPLE
IN JAIL.
>> Jesse: EVEN COLIN
KAEPERNICK IS LOOKING FOR A JOB.
>> Juan: THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
>> Jesse: I WANT TO GET BACK
TO WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
EARLIER ABOUT THE PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY, OR FATIGUE.
EVEN INDEPENDENTS HAVE TUNED
THIS OUT.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES," THEY DON'T
EVEN KNOW WHAT TO BELIEVE
ANYMORE AFTER THE RUSSIA
COLLUSION THING.
>> Dana: I'D LIKE TO BRING UP
THAT "NEW YORK TIMES" PIECE.
BASICALLY IT SAID THAT THERE IS
SO MUCH INFORMATION, TOO MUCH
INFORMATION, AND THE BODY IS
UNDERSTANDING, FOLLOWING THE
WHOLE STORY.
NOBODY TRUSTS THE MEDIA.
I SHOULDN'T SAY NOBODY --
>> Greg: NOBODY TRUSTS THE
MEDIA.
>> Dana: 65% OF LIBERALS,
THAT'S A PRETTY LOW NUMBER.
BASICALLY WHAT IT SAID IS THERE
HAS BEEN SO MUCH STUFF THERE AND
AGAINST THE WALL THAT PEOPLE ARE
NOT PAYING ATTENTION TO ANY OF
IT AND THEY ARE FIGURING THEY'LL
JUST WAIT UNTIL THE END, FIND
SOMEBODY THEY TRUST, READ A
COUPLE OF PLACES THEY FEEL THEY
CAN BELIEVE IN, AND MAKE A
DECISION AT THAT POINT.
MY MOM, SHE'S IN SANTA FE, THEY
ARE TOURING.
THEY AREN'T PAYING ATTENTION TO
THIS STUFF.
>> Jeanine: ALL THE EVIDENCE